it's kind of unrealistic and can be
destructive to place the responsibility
for your happiness on anybody other than
yourself
it's Nina's fault that I'm not happy
where you Nina success completely
misunderstood rise and shine it's an
espresso time what's up belief nation
it's Evan I believe in you and this
channel is designed to be part of your
daily success routine so let's start
your day off right to get there grab
your coffee and sip on today's message
take responsibility for your happiness
over to you will smith also if you'll
now know Will Smith has to say about
confidence and excellence check out my
254 series where every day for the next
254 days I will send you a morning video
for free to help you build your
confidence the links to join are in the
description below
I was excited about taking a shot the
fact that it was so strange you know as
an artist it was it was a fun to get out
on that on that limb and hoping it
doesn't break under your feet it takes
such a desperate obsessive focus to to
excel on assert honor on the level that
I want to make movies
[Music]
so me and Jada was reflecting about love
and I asked her I said what does she
think was you know one of the biggest
revelations that she had about love she
said that you cannot make a person happy
and I thought that was a real deep idea
you can make a person smile you can make
a person feel good you can make a person
laugh but whether or not a person is
happy is deeply and totally and utterly
out of your control
I remember today I retired I literally
said to Jada that's it I retire I retire
from trying to make you happy I need you
to go make yourself happy and just prove
to me that is even possible and after we
cracked the hell up we started talking
about we came into this false romantic
concept that somehow when we got married
that we would become one and what we
realized is that we were two completely
separate people on two completely
separate individual journeys and that we
were choosing to walk our separate
journeys together but her happiness was
her responsibility and my happiness was
my responsibility and we decided that we
were going to find our individual
internal private separate joy and then
we were going to present ourselves to
the relationship and to each other
already happy not coming to each other
begging with our empty cups out
demanding that she fill my cups and a
cup and demanding that she meet my needs
unfair and it is it's kind of
unrealistic and can be destructive
to place the responsibility for your
happiness on anybody other than yourself
your entire life changes when you decide
to take responsibility for where you're
at for it for your happiness for your
success for you where you're at in life
when you decide that I am responsible
everything changes we don't want to
because it's easier to blame somebody
else it's easier to blame somebody else
we don't to blame the person in the
mirror we don't blame ourselves it's
somebody else's fault right it's Nina's
fault that I'm not happy where are you
Nina right it's so good to put the blame
on somebody else because that means I
don't have to do anything but when you
take the personal responsibility when I
say it's my fault that I'm not happy
it's my fault that I'm not more
successful it's not my team's fault that
my company's not blowing up as big as I
wanted to it's my fault I need to get
better it's not my trainers fault that
I'm not getting results in the gym it's
my fault right I gotta eat better I
gotta work out more it's my fault
it's your fault you are where you are
because of you and when you accept that
then you choose to now live a life I'll
be able to make progress most people
don't want to do that most people would
rather consume entertainment instead of
education most people would rather
consume entertainment and sit down and
watch Netflix and forget about their
crappy life and try to fix it most
channels on YouTube that blow up are not
education related they're entertainment
because people want to shut up their
lives
shut up their brain and just be
entertained instead of trying to
actually fix the problem if you're a
subscriber here you're probably under
the kitchen side but are you the kind of
person who's gonna take responsibility
and fix your life or just shut up the
world blame complain which you can't
have that next vacation you can't wait
till that next weekend in the evenings
are coming up because your life sucks
your life sucks is it your fault or
somebody else's when you think ownership
that's when life starts to change so how
do you do it
create take order should take
responsibility how do you do it how do
you get happy or how do you get more
success what's what are the steps what
do I have to do maybe three-step process
follow this will change your life step
number one take the mirror test
you go up to a mirror go up to miracle
in your bathroom kitchen living room
kitchens kind of weird if I move I'm
here in our kitchen no living room
bathroom closet find the mirror and ask
yourself why are you not happy why are
you not more happy
well you're not more successful why are
you not whatever whatever the biggest
negative in your life why if the answer
comes back that it's somebody else
you have to fix it you have to keep
asking the question okay it's not my
wife's fault it's not my friends faults
out my parents fault it's not the
president's fault it's not the
government's fault it's not my school
teachers fault why and has to be
something here it's got to be something
with you you're not happy because it's
something you are thinking because in
the store in your head because your mind
said your actions you keep asking the
question why you are not happy until it
comes back to you and then you're gonna
uncover some scary truth you can uncover
some story about yourself
and listen we all have something guys we
all have something there's something we
don't like about ourselves it's okay own
it this is the thing that we're gonna
work on this is your path this is your
salvation is how you fix things so step
number one is take the mirror test if
you grow what the heck the thing is that
is making you so unhappy but it's
blocking you from having success in your
business what is it you got to get to an
answer and it's got to be all about you
somehow step number two is in create
your own 2:54 so it takes up to two
hundred fifty four days that consecutive
actions build a habit it's why I started
the 2:54 confidence black excellence
right a wisdom series and I want to do
more but I can only do so much you need
to create your own tool to support and
what I mean by that is you need to now
surround yourself with the kind of
people resources knowledge information
motivation of that thing that you need
to work on so example if you need to
work on having more belief in your life
then my channel is a great place to be
you should watch a video every single
day you will get more belief in yourself
it will just happen you take the mirror
test and the answer is I don't believe
in myself enough that's why I'm not
happy that's why I'm not more successful
great I need to surround myself with
belief every single day because chances
are you don't have people who believe in
you enough it's just not in your
environment so you need to inject that
in you need to inject it into your daily
routine watch your video every single
day
great it was something else my channel
may not be the right fit for you but you
can get it somewhere else whatever you
need whatever that answer is self care
self love whatever that answer is then
you need to find a way to create your
own 2:54 around that thing or every day
for the next 254 days maybe for life you
inject it into yourself you watch a
video you read a book you listen to a
podcast you have an interview you do a
phone call whatever it is every single
day you repeat that happen over and over
and over and over again and it will seep
into you and you will slowly lose that
thing and that thing that has been
holding you back for your entire life
will now allow you to move forward and
actually be happy and actually go up to
your success so you take the mirror test
and then to you create your own 2:54
around the thing that you need to work
on and then step number three is take
immediate action just thinking about it
just witnessing it is not enough action
action think about it for the next 24
hours what could you do what could you
do today you're watching this video
after this you want to develop this
skill set this mindset this new belief
system that's what you need to work on
you know this thing is holding you back
and it's limiting you what are you gonna
do right now just start building some
action and momentum towards it get out
of your head stop thinking stop planning
and just do something I call it the 2%
difference don't worry about how you're
gonna get to 100% perfect you'll never
get there anyway don't worry about that
don't plan plan plan all the way because
you keep planning tomorrow you gonna
wake up and you're a different person
you're back to your old self you need
immediate momentum you need action so
take any idea that you have you want to
be more belief person great what can you
do right now to believe in yourself more
what can you do what makes your heart go
like this what are you scared of doing
what idea first comes into mind that
idea was given to you for a reason
do it ISA right now commit to somebody
take that action not just researching
not just planning immediate action build
momentum teach yourself that you're the
kind of person who now follows through
who when you get an idea you take some
action on it follow that three-step
process
you're unhappy in life you want more
success in life take the mirror test
figure out deep inside you why you're
the problem what you're doing that's
limiting yourself to create your own
2:54 so that you are rounded daily so
that when you're around successful
people who have the skill that minds is
a belief system that you need it seeps
into you because you're rounded every
single day and then the three action
momentum immediately today do something
start showing yourself that you are
capable of being that person accept
responsibility for your life and you
will change your life dramatically for
the better now I've got a really special
bonus tip that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that question of the
day I want to know what immediate change
can you make to your life to make you
happier let me know in the comments
below
happiness is so important I'm so
obsessed with it right now and I hate
that success and entrepreneurship and
all this stuff have been put on a
pedestal do you understand that most
people think they need to make a million
dollars a year to be like winning
meanwhile in America one of the richest
countries in the world four hundred
forty thousand dollars is the entry into
the 1% we have we have success
completely completely misunderstood we
have success completely misunderstood
let me tell you what success looks like
when you wake up in the morning and
you're happy we need to define what
success means for us we need to redefine
what success means let's not make
happiness and success about the size of
our homes but about the size of our
heart let's not make it about
gratification but gratitude we speak
about being healthy and our well being
but we act more like human doings than
we do like human beings and therefore
instead of to-do list we need to be list
instead of conclude about what you want
you think about who you want to be you
want to be more self-aware do you want
to be more conscious do you want to be a
better person you want to be a
difference in the world we need to move
away from what we want to do in
situations to really want to be in
situations the three most common things
that we forget when we're rushing out of
our homes is our keys our wallet or our
mobile phone and it's absolutely
hilarious how you run back inside you
look in all your drawers you're looking
at desk you make a mess sometimes and
then how many times have you had it that
you realize it was actually in your back
pocket sometimes even in your hand and
it's funny that our experience of
happiness is so similar to this we run
around trying to find it in absolutely
every place but actually when we come
back home we find out that it's within
and if you want more Will Smith check at
the top 15 rules video that I made on
him the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there you got
to take a shot you have to live at the
edge of your capabilities you gotta live
where you're almost certain you're gonna
fail